こんばんは
下にです
今日はこの場合ザクでとても光栄です
戦記パトリー
皆さん多分英語のプレゼンテーション続いたんですね
集中してかなり疲れていらっしゃると思うので
私ちょっと日本語でプレゼンさせてもらえるかなと脚
いうふうに思っています宜しくお願いします
たくさんの外国人がですね
東京を訪れるように
なりましたか
昨年は約2000万人の訪日外国人が
これから2020年に向けてさらにですね
多くの外国人がへ
に言われています
た投票のですね何が彼らを
魅了しているのでしょうか
テルアビブから始めて東京にやってきた私の友人がですね
こう言いました
被災3東京は妖精の街だね
妖精
西洋でもない投票でもない何か
とてもユニークな場所
彼がそういう風に感じだみたいです
東京に住んでいる私たち日本人にはなかなかそういうことを感じることができません
日常生活の中で客観的な目線を持ってみるというのはなかなか難しいことなんですね
東京が世界一の街になるためにはこういった外国人の目線とかあるいは
旅行者とかツーリストの目線
こういった目線を持ってイマイチとですね
街を見渡してみることが大事なのかなと言う
それでは早速ですね
ツーリストの目線で
東京を眺めてみましょう
初めて東京を訪れるツーリストはですねこう感じます
東京には何かガイドブックに載ってない自分たちの知らない目に見えないルールがある
んじゃないかな
時にそれはですね不安を
煽るんです
ですが東京人のように東京を楽しむためには
どうしても
これを克服しなきゃいけないです
最初の関門は
渋谷のスクランブル交差点です
1回に最大3000人が渡ると言われている世界デー
とも混雑しているこの交差点
ビートルズ有名なロンドンのアビーロード
横断歩道がありますけれども
それよりも今
渋谷のスクランブル交差点の方が人気のスポットかもしれません
私たち東京に住んでいるものは
あのスクランブル交差点を渡るときにマーサして
苦労して渡ることはないんですけれども
ツーリストの目から見たらですね
なぜあれだけの人の波の中をぶつからずに
あるいは頃バル転がることもなく転ぶこともなくですね
目的の場所にわたっていけるのか
が非常に
主義に
思うみたいです
アビーロードの
アビーロードでは
ただ車に気をつけてですね横断歩道でビートルズのふりをして写真を撮ればいいんです
けど
指輪のスクランブル交差点では
迫り来るですね人の大群に向かって勇気を振り絞って
飛び込まなければいけない
渋谷のスクランブル交差点はですね
攻略できたら次に待っているのは投票名物の満員電車
わざわざ混雑する時間帯に
駅員のですね人たちにこう背中を押してもらって
すし詰めの車両に入ってみたい
そういう体験をしたいということで
やってくる兵たちが
いる東京のですね
体験型の
人気アトラクション
満員電車で困ることっていうのは
駅に到着した時にですね
をれる人の流れ
押し出さずですね
列車を降りてしまう
自分の目的の駅であればそれで構わないんですけれども
ここは僕はおり lake じゃないよという時に人の流れがわっと押し寄せて来て
ですね
ホームの方に幸をされていくといやいや僕はここに折れるんじゃないよって必死になっ
ていこう
踏ん張ってしまうんですよね
そうすると
ただの
迷惑な障害物になってしまうんです
私たちは
ルールがわかってますから一度それを理解できれば
押し寄せる波に身をまかせてホームにいったん降りていっ
降りる人が終わるのを待ってもう1回乗ればいいじゃないかとわかるんですけれども
ツール人たちは初めて経験しますから
ここで押し流されたら大変なことになると思って一生懸命
踏ん張ってしまうんですね
東京に行ったら
玄関で靴を脱いだね
日本通の友人に言われたりあるいはガイドブックを読んでー
ツーリストたちは東京に行ってきます
食事に行く時にレストランの玄関で
靴を脱いでー
上がります
靴を脱ぐ仕草が結構サマになってきたなっ
思いながら食事を楽しみます
途中で
トイレに立ちたくなってトイレに向かっていくと
なぜかスリッパが置いてある
ちょっと不安になりますけれどもスリッパを履いて
8たします
行たし終わったあとに
席に戻ろうとすると定員3人あっお客さんすいません
そのままでも取られたちょっと困ります
呼び止められるんですね
困惑します
脱ぐのか吐くのか
吐くのか塗るのか
トイレのスリッパの使い方まではガイドブックには書いてないんですね
このようにですね私たちの身近には私たちも気づいてない
見えないルールが
色々とあるんです
次は
ツーリストの目線を持って
自分たちのですね日常の生活見渡してみたいと思います
世界に伝えたい日本の魅力ってなんですか
問うと大体の人が世界遺産や
有名な観光地をあげるんですね
でももっと身近に私たちも気づいてないような
魅力が潜んでるんじゃないでしょうか
タクシー
日本ではタクシーのドアを開ける必要がありません
自動ドアだからです
私たち逆に海外に行った時にタクシーの料金を払い終わった後そのままずっと座ってい
てドアが開くのを待っていたり
あるいはタクシーを止めたときに
ドアが開くのただ立って待っていて運転士の1に軽減な顔で見られたりすることがあり
ます
タクシーなどは私たちにとっては日常ですけれども
いる人たちにとっては
ちょっと
不思議な
面白い体験なんですね
今日本全国がおもてなし症候群のかかっているようです
当時各おもてなしをしなきゃいけないよねおもてなしをしだけ
躍起になっています
そんな中でツーリストにお好み焼きが人気なんです
海外で言えばお金を払うのになんで自分で作らなきゃいけないんだとぅ
クレームになるようなそういうスタイルなんですけれども
自分で素材を選んで自分で料理して食べる
こういうおいしい体験が今ツーリストにとても人気です
頭が非でも
面倒を見てあげる
すべて面倒を見てあげるそれがおもてなしということではなくて楽しい経験を提供して
あげることがおもてなしだということ
あとはよそ行きなことじゃなくてもまあ効果のことじゃなくても
楽しい体験が提供できれば
それがおもてなしになるんだということを
お好み焼きが教えてくれています
ダースベイダー氏タイプ
2012年でですねバレンシアガとアレクサンダーマックイーン
キャットウォークにサンバイザーを登場させて非常に話題になりました
しかし皆さんご存知の通りサンバイザーというのは日本の夏の風物詩なんですね
夏が来ると強い日差しを避けるために
サンバイザーを身に付けた女性たち
あるいはママさんたちが街にあふれます
そういう意味では日本の女性たちというのはもう何年もですね
世界のファッションリードしているファッションリーダーと言えるかも知れませ
それではツーリストっていうのは何なんでしょうか
ういる人にとって大事なことって何でしょう
好奇心です
旅先で私たちは好奇心の塊です
限られると滞在期間の中で
見たことないものを見たい
聞いたことのないことを聞きたい
地元の人に会いたい
いろいろな体験をしたい
好奇心の赴くままに行動します
今まで出会ったことのない文化に出会いいい
それを理解しようとする
好奇心は人生を豊かにするんですね
一方デー
日常生活がルーティン化していくと
好奇心はだんだんと影をひそめていきます
小さい頃に知らないものに出会った時のワクワクするあの感じを取り戻すこと
多様な価値観をもった人たちが集まり交流し
クラスこれからの街
そこに住むとし西沙生活者たちは
無関心ではなくてこの好奇心
大事なのではないでしょうか
最後に
ツーリスト
務め戦になるための
3つの
方法
皆さんに紹介したいと思います
一つ目
スニーカーを買う
澄川数リストの命です
歩くということはすごく大事なんですね
二つ目
あえて迷子になってみる
いつもかようになれたら通勤通学の道から一本裏道に入ってみる
あるいは
ちょっと横道にそれで見る
そうすると今まで見たことの前でやったことのない新しいものである可能性があります
爪
これはちょっとやるのにハードルが高いかもしれないんです
知らない人に声をかける
変な人が乗って思われるビスクラちょっとあります
知らない人との出会いというのは今まで想像だにしたことのない世界の広がりようです
提供してくれる可能性があります
ただ季節は春なんで
島谷はいろんな人が集まってきます
話しかけるときには十分吟味して声をかけてください
みなさんそれぞれそれぞれのですね日常生活の中で
ツーリストになってみると
いうことを実践して
好奇心をくすぐる
人生の
探索と発見をですね楽しんでもらえたら嬉しいなと思っています今日はありがとう
ございました